Turkey's advance appears unstoppable the
center of Tel Abyad falling today it was
one of the first targets of this
operation against US backed Kurds Syrian
rebels fighting with Turkey are in a
celebratory mood everything will return
to that way it was justice has returned
to its rightful owners with the help of
the brothers in the frisian army and the
turkish army
[Music]
celebrations also broke out across the
border in the turkish town of actually
Turkey's president quick to seize the
initiative we will complete the
operation by taking has a car on the one
part and the iron al-arab on the other
we will advance 30 to 35 kilometers into
Syrian territory president Erdogan is
going deeper into Syria than previously
thought
even as NATO allies urge him to stop now
hundreds of US forces are being pulled
back they fear their Kurdish partners
will ally with the Syrian regime backed
by Russia we have American forces likely
caught between two opposing advancing
armies and it's a very untenable
situation so I spoke with the president
last night after discussions with the
rest of national security team and he
directed that we began a deliberate
withdrawal of forces from northern Syria
these pictures from a camp holding
Islamic state families will be a blow to
departing troops the Kurds say they show
a mass breakout following Turkish
shelling on the front line there's
concern about possible war crimes
Turkey's proxy rebels are accused of
executing two prisoners and killing a
politician innocent victims on the
Turkish side as well a suspected Kurdish
shell punched a hole in this apartment
block in act Chuckle a shattering The
Morning Calm this is where the blast
impacted the elderly couple who live in
this apartment were at home at the time
but escaped serious injury the attack
however has
prompted outrage on the streets outside
the couple's son is upset angry and
defiant if we die we die here we are not
going to go will not take down the
Turkish flag for my building I don't
care if they shoot to do again but
Turkey has the overwhelming firepower
the question is whether brute strength
will bring about peace there behind Sky
News Akaka lay on the turkey-syria
border